[Aerial view of buildings surrounded by trees.]
[Closer view of buildings including a large smokestack.]
[Aerial view of many buildings surrounded by hills and trees.]
[Closer view of several buildings.]
[View of a compound of buildings of various sizes.]
[Far aerial view of buildings with trees in foreground.]
[Camera pans the area surrounding the buildings from a distance.]
[View of the buildings from ground level.]
[View of the grounds and people on a swing.]
[Trees with people seen walking among them.]
[Close-up of flowers on a tree.]
[One of the bigger buildings is shown with people walking into it.]
[A pickup truck drives by the building.]
[A structure with floor and roof but no walls is shown.]
[Camera pans small structures on short stilts and shows two open buildings that are filled with chairs.]
[A building with a porch is shown. Nurses in uniform are shown descending the front stairs in pairs.]
[The nurses walk down a pathway and walk in between the trees.]
[The nurses are shown standing on the front stairs of a building in a group. They are smiling and talking to one another.]
[A building is shown with people coming out of it.]
[Close-up of the door of the building. People can be seen inside the building.]
[Men go into and out of the building. The sign above the door says "Cooperative Store."]
[The camera pans around the inside of the store.]
[The outside of a big building is shown.]
[The outside of a building which has flower vines growing on it is shown.]
[A fence is shown with a bird on it.]
[The outside of a bigger building is shown.]
[Men are shown in a structure with low walls but no roof, lying down, sunbathing and turning over.]
[Three men are shown standing wearing underwear.]
[They are laughing and two men playfully hit one another.]
[The sunbathing men are shown.]
[Some men are fully dressed and standing.]
[An attendant fully dressed in white shirt and pants is shown with four men wearing underwear.]
[The attendant is pointing out something about the men and smiling.]
[Two of the men change places.]
[The attendant is shown.]
[Another attendant is shown standing in a corner of the roofless structure, dressed in all white clothing and wearing a hat.]
[Men are sitting backwards on chairs outside a building with a nurse watching them.]
[Close-up of a man sitting in a chair. There is a mirror attached to the chair. The man is holding his mouth open and sticking his tongue out. The sun is reflected into his mouth.]
[The group of men is shown again. The nurse is talking to them.]
[A building is burning and is completely engulfed in flames. Two people are watching it burn.]
[Another building next to the burning building is already almost completely burned down.]
[People are watching the burning building.]
[Men walk away from the burning building.]
[A man with a cat next to him is feeding a small deer from his hands.]
[The deer walks around and a girl walks over to the man and cat.]
[The girl is shown petting the deer as it licks her dress.]
[A train is shown coming toward the camera. There are buildings on both sides of the tracks.]
[There are two cars to the train. It stops in front of the station and men, women and children get off the train.]
[The train porter helps people off the train.]
[The people exiting the train walk away from it in front of the station.]
[Several pickup trucks are shown. They have canvas coverings over the back of the pickup.]
[One truck drives away and there are people seated on benches in the back of it.]
[The trucks back up to steps and people get out of the back.]
[The people have tags around their necks and many are holding things.]
[The people, many of them boys, walk away from the truck.]
[A nurse is sitting at a table with a small boy. She is talking to him and writing. Along the edge of the table are signs with the letters: S, T, U, W, X, Y, Z.]
[Another nurse is sitting behind a table talking to a boy and writing.]
[A nurse is sitting behind a table with a small boy sitting in a chair in front of her. She is taking his temperature and pulse rate.]
[The boy stands up and walks away while another small boy gets into the chair.]
[The nurse also takes the temperature and pulse rate of the second boy who then gets up and walks away.]
[The nurse talks to the boy and hands him a package.]
[A woman has a small boy sitting in front of her and she covers his neck and shoulders with cloth.]
[The woman combs the boy's hair and then gets the clippers and shaves his head.]
[A room with many sinks is shown filled with boys who are pushing each other as they wash up and brush their teeth.]
[The boys push each other in fun.]
[There is one mirror and the boys push each other out of the way trying to use it.]
[Three boys wearing only underwear are shown.]
[The boys turn around so their backs are to the camera.]
[Four more boys are shown wearing only underwear and then turn their backs to the camera.]
[The boys turn around again to face the camera.]
[Three young girls are shown wearing only underwear. They turn all the way around until they are facing the camera again.]
[Two older girls face the camera wearing outfits that cover them up on both top and bottom.]
[The girls turn around and then face the camera again. They then smile.]
[Two young boys wearing underwear are shown smiling.]
[The boys turn alll the way around.]
[Two more boys are shown. One of the boys turns so his back is to the camera. The other boy is turned sideways by a man partially off-camera.]
[The second boy is then turned so his back is to the camera.]
[The turn back to face the camera looking at the man off-screen.]
[An older boy wearing underwear turns his back to the camera and then turns back to face the camera.]
[A very thin young girl is shown outside wearing only underwear.]
[Close-up of the young girl which focuses on her chest where her ribs are clearly visible.]
[The girl turns her back to the camera and then turns back.]
[The girl is shown from a distance again.]
[The girl turns to the side.]
[Boys are outside lined up to get a drink. The drinks are in a dispenser and a man is dispensing the drinks.]
[One after the other the boys get drinks.]
[Close-up of a boy getting his drink, which seems to be milk.]
[More boys get drinks.]
[Many boys are walking around outside drinking their milk.]
[Boys are shown standing in a line drinking their drinks.]
[Children are shown walking around outside next to a large building.]
[The children are lining up in between ropes]
[The children are lying down on the grass on towels. They all turn over from lying on their fronts to lying on their backs.]
[Close-up of a boy's striped underwear which is torn and tied together in a knot.]
[The boys are shown turning over again. There is an attendant standing among them.]
[The boys are lying under strips of material which keeps the sun off their faces. There are two nurses shown standing among the boys.]
[The children sit up and then turn over again.]
[The front of a big building is shown with a nurse standing on the porch. The children are holding towels and come rushing out of the building and down the stairs.]
[There is a nurse in the group of children who is carrying a child in her arms.]
[The children are shown standing around in a grassy field.]
[Boys and girls are shown standing next to their beds in a big room.]
[Another room of children is shown.]
[The children sit down next to their beds and then stand back up.]
[The children are at the end of their beds and they turn towards the doorway where some adults have entered the room.]
[The children salute the adults. There is a man accompanied by three nurses. He is looking at a chart.]
[The man walks down the center aisle in between two rows of beds talking to the nurses and looking at the hands of the children.]
[The adults are walking toward the camera.]
[The nurses are talking to the children and looking at their hands.]
[The man has his back to the camera and is talking to the children.]
[The children all turn to face the camera and salute.]
[The children back up along their beds and sit down in chairs.]
[Another room of children is shown standing by the ends of their beds. There are girls on the left and boys on the right.]
[A man and three nurses are shown walking down the middle aisle as the children salute them.]
[The man and the nurses check the hands of the children.]
[A boy is sitting in a chair with the sun shining on his face.]
[A person mostly off camera is rubbing something on the boy's upper lip.]
[Something is rubbed on the boy's fingernails and on his knee.]
[An older boy is having something rubbed on the bridge of his nose. The boy stands up and leaves.]
[A boy is having something rubbed on his thigh and then a bandage is applied.]
[Something is applied to a boy's foot, which is then bandaged.]
[A boy is being examined by a person off-camera. Something is rubbed on the boy's face and tweezers are used.]
[A boy is given a shot in his hand.]
[A close-up of the shot being administered is shown.]
[More images of injections are shown.]
[A girl shows the inside of her arms and someone off-camera points out something on her arms.]
[A close-up of an arm is shown. It has a red inflamed bump on it.]
[Another child has a bump or lesion on the arm.]
[A boy is shown with a bump on his arm.]
[Close-ups of bumps. lesions, and dark spots on the arms are shown.]
[Fuzzy picture of five children holding out their arms.]
[An older girl is shown in bed. She is working on a crossword puzzle and is smiling.]
[Two women are shown sitting on a bed doing sewing work.]
[Four girls are shown playing cards while sitting on a bed.]
[Four girls are shown playing parcheesi.]
[Four other girls are shown playing cards using a parcheesi board for a table.]
[Someone hands one of the girls a fancy pillow that looks like a flower.]
[A nurse hands a girl a thermometer. The girl is in bed in a room with other girls in bed.]
[The other girls are all using thermometers also.]
[The nurse walks back to the first girl and checks the reading on the thermometer. She shakes down the thermometer and records the results on a pad.]
[A nurse is shown taking the pulse rate of a young girl.]
[Young children are lined up outside getting drinks.]
[A man is dispensing the drinks to the children.]
[The long line of children is shown.]
[The children are standing around drinking their drinks.]
[Young boys are building a structure using logs. Three boys lift a log and hand it to other boys who are on the top of the structure.]
[Two young boys are boxing while a large group of children watch them.]
[Two other young boys box while the group watches.]
[One boy knocks the other boy down.]
[Two girls box while other boys and girls watch them. An attendant watches the match.]
[Four boys are shown on two stand-up teeter-totters going up and down.]
[In the background are children playing on playground equipment.]
[It has a platform for people to stand on and a bar to hold on to while it spins around a pole going up and down as the weight is shifted.]
[Children are sitting on the top of monkey bars while other children are going from bar to bar underneath them.]
[Children in the background are swinging on swings.]
[A girl hangs upside down from one of the monkey bars.]
[The rest of the children hang from the bars.]
[Children are playing on playground equipment.]
[Children are holding boards with clay on them.]
[The children have made animals and other things from the clay.]
[Children are playing with a ball in a swimming pool.]
[A boy and then a girl jump into the pool.]
[Children are getting out of the pool and then sliding down a slide back into it.]
[Children are swinging on a swingset. Some are swinging two to a seat.]
[Two children are straddling a bench and playing jacks.]
[Two older girls are sitting on a bench playing jacks. Another girl is sitting on the ground watching them. She then joins in the game.]
[A girl in front of the bench is waving a branch around.]
[There are several children sitting on the grass. One girl is stringing beads as the others watch her.]
[Many people are shown outside in front of a big building. There is snow on the ground and some children are sledding.]
[Many children are sledding down the hill, then walking back to the top.]
[Children are rolling snow into a ball to make a snowman.]
[A small group of children are having a snowball fight.]
[A large group of children are having a snowball fight.]
[Children are swinging on a long glider.]
[Many children are playing on playgroud equipment. It has a platform for people to stand on and a bar to]
[hold on to while it  spins around a pole going up and down as the weight is shifted.]
[Children are swinging on a long glider. There is a boy at each end using his body weight to keep the glider going.]
[An attendant is helping children to get drinks from a dispenser.]
[The man is dispensing the drinks. There are adults watching the children in the background.]
[Adults are preparing food for the children.]
[The children are lined up with attendants watching them.]
[Camera pans across children seated on the grass, eating and drinking.]
[Boys are putting pajamas on and getting into bed.]
[A nurse is seated behind a table and two boys are standing next to it. The nurse is writing.]
[Two nurses are standing outside talking to each other.]
[One nurse walks away and we see a man in a suit.]
[One nurse is shown, standing outside.]
[Nurses in uniform are standing on the outside steps of a building. They have capes or coats on over their uniforms.]
[A man and a woman are talking to each other.]
[Four nurses are shown comng out of a building. Two of the nurses are holding hands.]
[A group of nurses are talking and laughing while seated outside.]
[Nurses are swinging on the swingset. Two are standing and three are seated. Another nurse is standing next a swing.]
[Nurses are shown talking and laughing.]
[Nurses are standing in a line with a man in a suit in the middle.]
[Five nurses are gliding on the glider.]
[Nurses are laughing and talking.]
[One nurse is in a car and several nurses are surrounding it.]
[Nurses are standing on the porch of a building and children are running down the stairs.]
[Little children are standing on the lawn of a building.]
[Boys and girls are shown talking to each other outside.]
[Children dressed in nice clothing pose for the camera.]
[Boys and girls are shown lined up on the sidewalk in a town.]
[Close-up of the children on the sidewalk.]
[A very large group of children is shown sitting and standing on the sidewalk in front of a large building.]
[A bus backs up in front of the group.]
[The children start to board the bus.]
[The bus is filled with children.]
[Older girls are shown boarding the bus under the direction of the nurses.]
[Older boys are on the street.]
[Girls are milling about on the street.]
[More children board a bus. Several buses are on the street.]
[Nurses are dishing out food from large pots.]
[Children are seated on the lawn eating. Several children wave at the camera.]
[Long camera view of the children marching as if in a parade. The children are divided into groups.]
[Some children make a sharp right turn.]
The groups continue marching.
[The children are shown saluting an American flag that is being lowered.]
[The flag is lowered to the bottom of the pole and is being held by someone.]
[Several children are holding the flag and folding it.]
[A truck with children riding in the back is shown. There are nurses and an attendant standing by the truck.]
[The truck leaves and some of the children wave to the camera.]
[Another truck is backed up to the stairs of a large building. Children are being loaded into the truck as an attendant oversees the loading.]
[Another truck loaded with people drives away. Some people wave at the camera.]
[Children are being loaded onto a train with the help of a nurse. Some of the children have suitcases or traveling bags.]
[The film ends abruptly.]